The following content is
provided under a creative
commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Couple of announcements.
First of all, the Wolf Lecture
is tomorrow, right here in
10-250 at 4:00.
As also, there will be the
weekly quiz, the mini
celebration.
But there's going to be, a week
from today, celebration
part trois.
Yes, third celebration
of learning.
And remember, what we're
shooting for
is the smiley face.
None of this.
And those of you who are over
here on the grade point
distribution curve, we want
to move you to the right.
So I'll say a little bit more
later in the week about what
the coverage will be.
I'll be available for office
hours later, and
I thought to try to cheer you
up, and remind you that
studying is not something
you do only the
night before the exam.
You have to be studying
on a regular basis.
All right?
So from the iconic film
Ghostbusters,
there's this one scene.
[FILM PLAYBACK]
For a moment, pretend that I
don't know anything about
metallurgy, engineering, or
physics, and just tell me what
the hell is going on.
You never studied.
[END FILM PLAYBACK]
You don't want to be a character
in that scene.
So what are you going
to do about it?
You're going to study.
All right.
Let's get down to work.
Today I'm going to take one
day and I'm going to talk
about organic chemistry.
Now, I'm not going to pretend
that after one lecture, you're
going to walk out of here and
know much organic chemistry.
I'm going to give you, if
you want to know organic
chemistry, you're going
to have to take 512,
and many if you will.
But I'm going to give you enough
that it will set up for
the subsequent units on polymers
and on biochemistry.
So we'll know enough that
we can move forward.
So let's get into the
definition of organic chemistry.
It's the chemistry of compounds,
containing both
carbon and hydrogen.
There can be, of course, other
elements present, but you've
got to have carbon and
hydrogen to get
yourself into Orgo.
And what makes carbon and
hydrogen so special?
We've been studying these
elements through the semester.
But just to be reminded.
First of all, hydrogen is
peculiar because it's got the
lowest atomic number.
It's got the lone proton,
and a single electron.
And when hydrogen ionizes,
it forms the
hydrogen ion, or the proton.
That's all that's left.
And this thing's very
tiny, and it can
form covalent bonds.
It forms covalent bonds as
primary bonds, and it can form
hydrogen bonds as
secondary bonds.
So it's peculiar for
that reason.
It does not form ions.
You cannot imagine something is
tiny as a proton occupying
a lattice site in an
ionic crystal.
OK.
Now when it comes to carbon,
carbon is also peculiar.
It's smack dab in the middle of
the periodic table, in the
second row.
Four valence electrons, which
means that it's very
difficult to ionize.
If it wants to achieve octet
stability, it's going to have
to form covalent compounds.
It's not going to acquire four
electrons or lose four
electronics.
In rare exceptional
circumstances it, might, but
commonly, it does not.
And with that intermediate
average valence electron
energy, it's going
to be capable of
all sorts of bonding.
And in particular, because of
its small size, it's capable,
with its small size and the
intermediate value of average
valence electron energy--
and this is critical--
is that it's capable of forming
multiple bonds.
And this is key, as we'll see
later when things try to
polymerize and form
multiple bonds.
And this is not common, for
example, not the case if you
look underneath carbon.
Silicon, germanium,
for example.
Same thing.
Group 4, same kind of mid-stream
average valence
electron energy.
But they're too big.
Silicon and Germanium do not
form double and triple bonds.
So the other thing is that it's
capable of self-linking.
It can link to itself, form
carbon chains, and also with
nitrogen, oxygen, sulfur.
So this gives it--
and let's put up phosphorus
as well.
Phosphorus and sulfur.
So with these kinds
of links-- we've
already seen oxygen links.
We'll see, pretty soon, nitrogen
links and so on.
There's millions of organic
compounds, and today I'm just
going to look at a few.
I'm just going to give
you some taxonomy and
nomenclature, and we're going
to walk through this.
And here's the way to
keep it straight.
You know all this stuff.
I'm just going to organize
it in your minds for you.
We've already studied the
three different types of
hybridization.
sp, sp2, and sp3.
And we've already seen that if
you're going to have a double
bond, you need sp2 hybridization
to reserve 1p
orbital, to make that
pi second bond.
And if you want to make triple
bonds, you make sp
hybridization, thereby reserving
two p orbitals to
make two pi bonds.
So this is sigma, sigma plus
pi, sigma plus pi plus pi.
That's it.
Now what we're going to do is to
is go back and look at this
in the context of
hydrocarbons.
So hydrocarbons is going to be
now the focus here, and the
hydrocarbons are the simplest
of the organic compounds.
So let's look at hydrocarbons.
I'm going to look at their
nomenclature and their
properties.
But the structure behind
everything, the treatment, is
the type of hybridization.
So these consist only of
hydrogen and carbon.
Compounds containing only
So I'm just going to
go down that chart.
And we'll go through.
So the first one on the left is
the alkanes We'll look at
the alkanes.
And the alkanes are
characterized by sp3
hybridization.
And so this gives the maximum
number of carbon linkages.
Why?
Because you can only
form single bonds.
So if I can only form single
bonds, every bond goes to a
different atom.
Whereas if I form double bonds,
then I'm burning up
some of the capability.
Because if I used two bonds
to get to one neighboring
element, instead of two single
bonds each to two different
neighboring elements, I don't
have as many linkages.
So the maximum number of carbon
linkages-- and because
they have the maximum number,
we're going to borrow
terminology from the last
unit on solutions.
What's the maximum amount of
solute you can get into a
solution called?
It's called the saturation
value.
And they use that term here.
These are called saturated
hydrocarbons, because they've
got the maximum number
of linkages, bonds.
And they're all sigma bonds.
All of this is a consequence
of the choice of sp3.
I could have led you through all
of this, but we're putting
it up quickly here.
All right.
And so they have a
common formula.
CNH2N plus 2.
I think I've got some--
yeah, this is taking from
one of the other books.
I know you've got a list like
this in your own book.
So here they are.
So this is just CNH2N plus 2,
and you go down, and there's
the nomenclature.
The meth, for historical reasons
represents n equals 1.
So here's what the hidden
message is.
You name them by the carbon
number plus the suffix A N E.
So the -anes, the alk-anes,
are all these sp3.
So 1 is meth, 2 is eth, 3
is pro, and 4 is but.
And they all have historical
derivations.
But- comes from butyric acid,
which is the acid that's
formed when butter turns
rancid, and so on.
After you get up to N equals
4, it's just your Latin.
So you just take your high
school Latin, pentane, hexane,
heptane, and so on.
And if you didn't take high
school Latin, this is a great
chance to learn the
ordinals in Latin.
So there they are.
Now, I'm not going to
expect you to--
if I say decane, you're supposed
to slam down C10H22.
But I would expect that I could
say decane, and I'd give
you that formula and you'd
be comfortable with it.
What's the other thing to note
here, while we've got this up
on the chart.
You can see that all of these
are symmetric molecules, and
they're non-polar.
They're perfectly symmetric
non-polar.
And what happens as the
molecular mass increases, the
melting point increases, the
boiling point increases, and
the state of matter transitions
from gas at room
temperature to liquid at room
temperature to solid at room
temperature.
So here's an excellent example
of polarizability in action.
Because the only way one methane
can bond to another
methane is by induced
dipole-induced dipole
interaction.
So the only difference between
methane and icosane is that
icosane is a honking big
molecule, non-polar, but very
polarizable.
And so as the polarizability
increases, you can see the
effect here.
OK, so that's good.
So you get to learn your
Latin ordinals.
Now these are also termed
straight chains.
They can be termed straight
chains, but I want you to look
carefully at what's
going on here.
So here's a diagram used, the
first one on the left, you've
seen methane many times.
There's ethane and
then propane.
And what do you notice here?
Because of the sp3
hybridization, all of these
angles are 109 degrees,
including the
carbon-carbon angles.
And when the thing is really
short, you get
this zig-zaggy nature.
So because of the sp3
hybridization, you see the
carbon doing this.
This is carbon-carbon, and
then the rest, forget it.
I mean, this is the backbone.
But if I get up to icosane and
I have about 20 of these
things, forget the zig-zag.
From here, yeah, I know there's
a little bit of fine
structure, but for all intents
and purposes, this as a chain.
Straight chain.
And that's where you get
the terminology from.
But keep in mind that there is
this zig-zagging back and
forth, due to the sp3
hybridization.
OK?
So that's the first point.
The second point is that the
bonds between the carbons are
not fully specified.
So for example, take the carbon
here on the left.
The sticks to go to the 3
hydrogens here depicted in
white, and then the fourth
stick goes to the carbon.
And then off of that carbon
comes 3 more sticks, and all
of these are 109
degree angles.
All of that specified,
and nothing more.
There's nothing saying that
these 2 hydrogens in the back
have to line up.
These two hydrogens out front
have to the line up.
That's all free to rotate.
And so we have that degree
of freedom there.
The result is that you can have
something that zig-zags
back and forth.
So for example, this is called
eclipse, because if I were to
stand here, these two hydrogens
are on a direct line.
So the front hydrogen covers
the back hydrogen.
It eclipses.
This hydrogen out front to your
and my right is on the
same line is this hydrogen
to your and my left.
And so if I were to look here
from the end, this hydrogen
eclipses, and so on.
So if I get something eclipsed,
I'm going to have a
perfect straight line.
If I have something that's
staggered, it's free to
zig-zag, but it's free to
zig-zag and meander, and this
is what happens.
So here's 2 C17H36 molecules,
and the top confirmation is
more or less straight.
These are more or less eclipsed
configurations.
Whereas the lower one, you can
see, there's a fair bit of
stagger, and as a result, the
backbone can actually loop
back on itself.
But in both cases, we still call
these straight chains.
They're still straight chain.
Because as you start at one
end and go from carbon to
carbon, you linearly go
to the other end.
It doesn't mean it's straight
like straight as an arrow.
It just means there's
no branches.
So now I'm going to distinguish
this from the
other one by branching.
So let's just get
this up here.
So we have straight chains,
is one case.
Straight chains.
And the straight chains
can either be
staggered or eclipsed.
And the closer you get
to eclipsed, the
closer you get to--
the more eclipsed,
the straighter.
I think you'll understand
what this means.
Staggered allows it to
make large loops--
I'll just put here, straight
but looped.
You can use that to describe
some of your friends, too.
All right.
Now--
it's a Monday, it's a joke!
Wake up!
All right.
Now we can look at
another one.
Branched chains.
And now, this will be a major
departure, whether the chain
is super-straight or does a lot
of looping back and forth,
the branched chain is in marked
contrast. Now let me
give you an example of
the branch chain.
Best to just do it.
So here's the branch chain.
I'm going to use a butane.
So you know B U T is 4.
So that means 4 carbons, and
A means 4 carbons, sp3
hybridized.
So that's it.
So now I'm going
to write this.
Here's butane.
C, C, C, C.
And I'm going to write this as
just a straight chain, instead
of doing this.
I'm going to contrast. I'm
going to do 1, 2, 3, 4.
1, 2, 3, 4.
OK?
So there we are.
So this is, instead of writing
all this stuff, this is
butane, and this is butane.
But now here's the thing.
Four stick rule.
Whenever you're doing Orgo,
four stick rule.
That means, four sticks
out of every carbon.
So here's the carbon-carbon
bond, so I
need three more sticks.
1, 2, 3.
And I know these are sp3
hybridized, but just, in
compressed notation,
you can do this.
And I'm not even going to
write all the hydrogens.
Here I'm going to write the
hydrogens because it's our
first time through, and it's
Monday, and everybody needs a
little bit of TLC.
But now the TLC is gone.
This is it, all right?
I'm not even going to put
the H's on the end.
The stick coming off of carbon
means there's a hydrogen here.
All right?
So how about this one?
1, 2, 3, 4, 1, 2, 3,
4, 1, 2, 3, 4.
And now let's count
the hydrogens.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10.
C4H10.
Butane.
All right.
Now there's another
way to write this.
I could go like so.
1, 2, 3.
And I could put a
carbon up here.
This is a branch, you see?
It's not in a straight line.
And I'm not talking
about eclipsed.
Because if I start at 1n and go
down the backbone, I get to
the other end, I
only hit three.
I never got to this one.
But let's see.
You know, maybe this
is different.
So four stick rule.
1, 2, 3, 4.
Now let's count the hydrogens.
1, 2, 3, 4, 4, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10.
This is C4H10.
It's a different molecule,
you can see.
With what you've already learned
in 3091, this has a
different dipole moment,
doesn't it?
It's got a different
dipole moment.
It's going to have a different
polarizability.
But it's a butane,
it's a C4H10.
So this is called
butane, right?
And this one, over here,
historically, was called isobutane.
Because it's an isomer.
It's got the same chemical
composition, but it's got a
different makeup.
It's got a different
structural makeup.
It's got a different--
I'm going to use the material
science-y word.
Different structure.
It's got a different molecular
structure.
But the chemists going back 50
years ago didn't use these
terms. They called it different
constituents.
So I'm going to use
that as well.
Different molecular structure
or different constituents.
And what do we mean
by constituents?
Now comes the color chalk.
So we're going to do,
is I want to circle
the makeup of this.
So at this end, I've got--
this is a CH3 here, correct?
There's a CH3 over here.
And then in between, I've
got CH2 and a CH2.
Now let's go over here
and diagram this one.
The isobutane, I've got a CH3
at the end, and a CH3 at the
opposite end.
So far, same as the butane.
But now look.
There's a third CH3 here,
and then there's this
thing, which is a CH.
You could argue it's
a CH2 that got
methylated, but, you know.
So I'm going to put a CH2 here
that's been methylated.
And I'll tell you
what that means.
OK?
So it's really a CH2 group
that got methylated.
So it's called isobutane, but
you can see, it's got
different--
all I'm doing here is making
the justification for the
different constitution,
different dielectric
constants, and so
on and so forth.
So this is where the chemists
must come in.
They would say, different
constituents.
And so these are isomers that
have the same chemical
composition, and are different
on the basis of their
constitution.
So they call these
constitutional isomers.
This is a constitutional
isomer.
Isobutane is a constitutional
Now the last piece
is nomenclature.
They don't use this today.
Because isobutane was
a term that came
out of chemical industry.
Because it looks like butane,
has got the same molecular
weight, but it's
very different.
Today we use the
IUPAC notation.
Remember this?
International Union of Pure
and Applied Chemistry.
They're the ones, when one of
you discovers and stabilizes
element 113, And you want to
name it after dadadadada, you
have to get past the
IUPAC committee.
OK?
So their nomenclature committee
would say, this is
an alkane, but it's only three
carbon units long.
So it is not a butane.
It is a propane.
It is a type of propane.
But it's not simple propane,
because there's a methyl
hanging off the side.
So in point of fact, this, in
IUPAC nomenclature, is a
methyl propane.
And furthermore, if you want
to get really pedantic, and
IUPAC loves to get pedantic, is
what they'll do, is they'll
number these, starting
from left to right.
So this is the number 1 carbon,
this is the number 2
carbon, and this is
number 3 carbon.
And the methyl group
is pendent on
the number 2 carbon.
So if we want to get really,
really, really pedantic, and
who wouldn't, on a Monday
morning, what we would do, is
we would call this
2-methylpropane.
So it's a propane, 3 carbon
units, there's a methyl group
hanging off of number 2.
Now, I don't expect you to be
able to do these on sight, but
I would like you to be
appreciative of what this is.
So I'll give it to
you on an exam.
All right.
So we've got the isomers.
And I think I've got some--
I think I've got this.
No.
OK, this is good.
Oh.
There's one other thing I want
to talk about with alkanes.
There's another thing that we
need to know, and that's about
the radicals.
The radicals that form.
The radical is a species
with one or
more unpaired electrons.
Right?
This is broken bond.
One pair electrons.
That's equivalent
to broken bond.
OK.
So this is highly reactive.
Because this unpaired
electron is going to
go look for a mate.
So if you take a look at CH4--
now I'm going to put
the hydrogens in.
So this is methane, CH4.
I'm going to break this bond in
the lower right corner, and
just have an unpaired
electron.
And this is called the
methyl radical.
Very reactive.
So you can see that this methyl
radical could go up and
stick on to the fourth strut of
that number 2 carbon, and
thereby form the carbon-carbon
bond.
So that's why they call
this methylpropane.
So the methyl radical.
And you can write it this way,
H3C with dot indicating
unpaired electrons.
But I want you to be literate
with the way chemists will
write this in various
compact notations.
So you might even see
it written this way.
Now, that doesn't mean
that the unpaired
electron is on a hydrogen.
This is just a way of saying,
you know, CH4 is methane, CH3
is methyl, and who cares.
There's only one possible
meaning to
this, so it's all good.
All right?
Let's do two unpaired
electrons.
So I'm going to take two
unpaired electrons.
Again, this is out of the
alkane, so I'll put a hydrogen
above and below.
So that would be like
this one here.
You see the CH2?
So it's got carbon-carbon bonds
on either side, but in
point of fact, this is
part of a zig-zag.
So I'm going to break
bonds here and here.
All right?
So now I've got the possibility
of putting a bond
on either side.
And this one here is
called methylene.
This is methylene.
This is the methylene radical,
and it's got
two unpaired electrons.
So we could write that as H2C
with 2 unpaired electrons.
And, you know, these
are electrons.
They're not just anywhere.
They're sitting in an orbital,
and that orbital is as at 109
degrees from the other bond.
So it has to be sitting there
in reserve, in waiting.
So if I bring another carbon
here, I get the carbon-carbon
bond, and I start forming
the zig-zag.
And there's one more, a common
one that we'll need to know.
And that's from ethane,
which is C2H6, right?
Let's start with ethane, C2H6,
and I'm going to make a
radical out of that.
It will be C2H5, like this.
To which I can add a hydroxyl,
and now I'll make ethyl
alcohol, and then
it's party time.
But so this is how you start.
All right?
This is the ethyl radical.
Starting from methane.
And that's pretty much it.
That's about all I want
you to really take
away with the alkanes.
C4H10.
Yeah, there you go.
So there you can see, to the
left, the zig-zagging of the
linear and the butane, and
then the methyl propane.
That's good.
OK.
Now let's go to sp2.
Now we're going to look
at the alkenes.
So alkenes represent--
the alkenes--
this is sp2 hybridization.
And they contain--
this means there's the
possibility of a carbon-carbon
double bond.
And they're also known
as unsaturated.
Because they don't optimize.
The fact that you spent two of
your bonds going between two
atoms instead of taking one bond
to one carbon and another
bond somewhere else, means that
you're undermaximized.
So unsaturated hydrocarbons.
OK?
And the formula for these is
CNH2N, where obviously N is
greater than 1.
We can't form a carbon-carton
double bond
with only one carbon.
So you know, the prototypical
one we looked at was this one
here, just to C2.
That's the first one.
So it's going to be C2H4.
So carbon-carbon double bond.
There's a sigma bond here,
and a pi bond.
And they lie in a plane.
The molecule is planar.
120 degrees here.
So we'll put the hydrogens
on it--
you know already, I don't have
to put the hydrogens there.
That's good enough.
All right.
So what's this one called?
This is called ethylene,
historically.
Ethylene.
But the IUPAC notation is
similar to this one.
It's carbon number
plus -ene, E N E.
So strictly speaking, this
is what everybody knows.
But IUPAC insists--
and I don't know.
As you publish, some editors
are really fastidious, and
they'll force you to change
if you use this kind of
terminology.
So you're going to have
to call it ethene.
Or in the UK they
call it ethene.
But everybody knows
it is ethylene.
OK.
So there it is.
And you only need 1
carbon-carbon bond.
So you can have long
chains where the
position isn't fixed.
So let's look at a couple
of examples.
So let's look at butene.
OK, let me just write
that down.
That's good.
The position of carbon-carbon
is not fixed.
It just has to be somewhere in
the molecule, which consists
only of hydrogen and carbon
So here's a couple
of examples.
I'll start with this one.
This is going to be--
so this is 1, 2, 3, 4, so
that's a but- something.
And it's got a double bond,
so that's a butene.
It's all hydrocarbon.
So that's butene here.
But I could also-- well,
let's finish this.
How many?
This is 1, 2, 3, 4.
See, I even tried to indicate
the 120 degrees here.
This is going to
be 1, 2, 3, 4.
1, 2, 3, 4, 1, 2, 3, 4.
All right.
So there's the butene.
But there's another place I
could put the carbon-carbon
double bond.
I could do it this way.
Make a carbon-carbon single
bond, move the carbon-carbon
double bond over to the
number 2 position.
this is 1, 2, 3, 4.
So this is going to be 1-butene,
and this one here is
going to be 1, 2.
So we'll make this 2-butene.
And let's keep counting here.
1, 2, 3, 4, 1, 2, 3, 4, 1,
2, 3, 4, 1, 2, 3, 4.
And I've proven to you,
I hope, by now that I
can count to four.
So this is 2-butene, right?
2-butene.
And if you go through this
using the same kind of
diagrammatic analysis as over
here, you're going to come to
the conclusion that even though
these both have the
same composition, which is going
to be C4H8, they're both
C4H8, but as you diagram them,
you'll find that they have
different constituents.
So these, in fact, are
constitutional
isomers of one another.
Constitutional isomers.
Yeah, that's pretty good.
There's even more.
It gets even better.
I want to focus on the bottom
one, the 2-butene, and I want
to write it out with a little
bit more detail.
So let's start with that
carbon-carbon double bond.
And we know the carbon-carbon
double bond requires planar
structures at 120 degrees
from one another.
So let's look at that one.
And what we've got here, is on
the carbon, I've got on the
one side, I've got a hydrogen
strut, right?
And on the other side,
I've got a methyl.
I've put a methyl
here, like that.
OK?
Or actually, let's get--
OK, I'll do that.
I was-- what I wanted to
do, to get really--
OK, watch this.
All right.
So what I'm going to
do on this side,
this side, same thing.
The carbon has a hydrogen strut
down here, and on the
other side, you've
got the methyl.
OK?
So that looks good.
But there's another way to do
this, and still keep the
carbon-carbon bond
in the center.
So I'm going to do
that over here.
So 1, 2, 1, 2.
And in this instance, I'll put
the same thing I have on the
left side, H3C.
So so far, so good.
I've got the same molecule.
But now what I'm going to do,
just for grins and chuckles,
I'm going to put the hydrogen in
the upper position, and the
methyl in the lower position.
Now, these are not
constitutional isomers.
They have the same constitution,
right?
Carbon-carbon double bond, two
methyl groups, two hydrogens.
So they're constitutionally
identical, yet these have very
different properties.
Can you see?
I mean, the dipole moment is
going to be different.
Look.
Here's the charge, all up on one
side, and here the charge
is more symmetrically
straddled.
Which means, they're going to
have different melting points.
They're going to have different
boiling points.
And they have the same chemical
formula, and they
have the same chemical
constitution.
So they're different kinds.
There's some kind of isomers--
what's the difference here?
It's not the constitution,
it's the way things are
arranged in space!
This is great material
science.
Spatial orientation
is everything.
And what do you call it when
you're listening to some
loudspeakers and a really good
audio system, and you can
close your eyes, and the violins
are over here, and the
cello is here, and
you can hear the
percussion way in the back.
What is that called?
Stereophonic sound.
Stereo phonic, meaning you can
render spacial resolution.
So these are called
stereoisomers.
One's a stereoisomer
of the other.
So they're spacially
distinguishable.
So they have--
for example, I went and
looked this up.
Oh.
Let's give some names to this.
In this case, all the methyls
are on the same side, and the
hydrogens are on
the same side.
So I can a dividing plane
here, if you like,
parallel to the floor.
And I'll just cut right through
the center of the
carbons, parallel
to the floor.
And so in one instance, all the
methyls are on the same
side, and here the methyls are
on opposite sides of the
double bond.
So when they're on the same
side, this is called
cis-butene.
And let's be super pedantic.
It was a 2-butene, so now
it's a cis-2-butene.
This is terrific.
And this is a 2-butene, but
it's on opposite side.
So this is called a
trans-2-butene.
Cis-2-butene and
And I looked up-- so let's see,
which one do you think
has tighter, which one's going
to be more tightly packed?
Which one's going to have
the greater density?
Which one's going
to pack better?
Cis or trans?
The density here is 0.627, and
the density here is 0.61.
OK?
Now, which one's going to have
the higher boiling point?
Which one's going to have the
higher boiling point?
Gee, that should be
a no-brainer.
Once you know which one's
got the higher density.
Why does it have the
higher density?
Because it's more nearest
neighbors is
more tightly packed.
So I would bet on the one
with the higher density.
And this one boils at, boiling
point is 3.7 degrees Celsius,
and this one, the boiling
point is--
hang on, I've got
this backwards.
This is 3.7.
Boiling point is 1
degree Celsius.
So those are the data
as they come up.
So stereoisomer, spacially
distinguishable.
By the way, we can form
multiple bonds.
We can form multiple
double bonds.
So they're -enes as well.
So if we have two double bonds
in the molecule, so we'll call
that a diene.
And we can have--
you can keep going with the
Latin, but common ones you
might find is the triene.
And this will come back later
when we look at polymers.
So if we have two bonds,
we will have--
You know, some of that hard
luggage that you're seeing
that's coming back, they got the
roller boards, but instead
of the fabric, now they're
coming back with the really
hard polymer?
That's ABS, and the
b is butadiene.
So let's look at a-- here's
a pentadiene.
I'll give you a pentadiene.
So that's going to
be 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
It's five carbons,
for starters.
And I'm going to put
the double bonds on
the 1 and the 3 carbon.
It'll be a penta-, it's
five carbons.
And it's an -ene, because
there's going to be some
double bonds here.
And it's a di-, because I'm
going to put double bonds at
the 1 and the 3.
So 1 gets a double bond, and
3 gets a double bond.
So this is a pentadiene.
OK?
And then the last thing is--
pardon me.
Last thing is radicals.
So here's the common radical.
We'll start with ethylene, and
I'm going to make an ethylene
radical here.
I'll break off the hydrogen at
this point, and I can write
that as CH2CH.
And we can't call this ethyl
radical, because ethyl was
already used for C2H5.
So we need to indicate that
there's a double bond, and so
this radical is known
as vinyl.
This is the vinyl radical.
And so you could react this with
chlorine, for example, in
which case you'd make vinyl
chloride, and then you'd
polymerize that, and
you make PVC.
And we're going to see that
in the next coming days.
Or you could you can put
alcohol on there.
I've already told you that.
I don't need to remind you
twice about that, I bet.
OK.
So now--
oh, there's one other one.
There's one other one that will
come up if you take a lot
of biochemistry, and
that's the one that
comes off of propene.
So if you start with propene,
propene's going
to look like this.
1, 2, 3.
So there's propene.
3.
There's a saying double bond
here, and I'm going to put 1,
2, 3 in here.
1, 2, 3, 1, 2, 3.
1, 2, 3, 4.
OK.
So this is the radical that
comes from propene.
So this one is derived from
ethylene, and this one here is
derived from propylene.
So again, as in this case, we
couldn't call this ethyl.
We can't call this propyl,
because that's the one that
you get from the alkane.
So instead, this one
is called allyl.
A L L Y L.
And if you take 7012 at some
point, Professor Weinberg will
refer to these pendant groups.
He likes to pronounce
this all-YL.
You'll hear him talk about,
and the all-YLS are
over here and here.
That's what we're
talking about.
OK, good.
So this is C3H7 dot.
Good.
All right.
Moving right along.
Now I want to turn
to the alkynes.
That's the sp hybridization.
sp.
And that means there's going
to be at least one
carbon-carbon triple bond.
One carbon-carbon triple bond.
So the formula there is CNH2N
minus 2, and obviously N has
to be greater than
1, otherwise you
can't form a bond.
And there's very little
that you need to
remember about this one.
The dominant one that you'll
come upon is C2H2.
So according IUPAC nomenclature,
the two carbons
means it has to be F, and these
are all alkynes, so this
should be ethyne.
And if you ask for ethyne,
nobody knows what you're
talking about, although
it's very correct.
This is known as acetylene,
which is a fuel gas for
welding, cutting, torches
and so on.
You've got two lines, you've got
a big tank of acetylene,
you've got a big
tank of oxygen.
And this is used because there
is enormous energy stored in
this carbon-carbon
double bond.
And so when you combust this
with the stoichiometric amount
of oxygen, you can cut through
steel, you can use this to
make very elaborate glassware
with pure silica, making fused
quartz glassware.
Very, very high energy
contained in here.
And just to give one more
example, let's look at
something that's got
four carbons in it.
So it's going to have four
carbons and a triple bond.
So if it's 4, it's going to have
the B U T but-, and it's
going to need an -yne.
So this will be a butyne.
And depending on where we want
to put the triple bond, I
don't know, if you want to
put a triple bond here,
there's 1, 2, 3, 4.
So this we could call 2-butyne,
and it's C4H6, If
you go through the
stoichiometry.
Let's try it, just
for practice.
So this carbon on the
end is 1, 2, 3, 4.
Look at the second carbon.
It's got one strut bonding to
the neighboring carbon, and
three struts bonding
to the neighboring
carbon on the right.
It's saturated now.
Nothing comes of
without carbon.
Look at this one.
1, 2, 3, 4.
Nothing comes off of this one.
And then finally 1, 2, 3.
So there's three hydrogens here,
there's three hydrogens
here, there's your
sixth hydrogen.
C4H6.
OK.
That's good.
All right.
There's one other set that I
want to look at, and these are
called the arynes.
These are aromatic
hydrocarbons.
Some people refer to
them as arynes.
And the most notable one is
C6H6, which is benzine.
And benzine's molecular weight
was determined long ago, in
the early 1800s.
And it was Kekule who, in 1865,
dared to suggest that
the chemical structure of
benzine was a ring structure.
So Kekule suggested
a carbon ring.
Up until this time, people
didn't have the common
understanding that carbons could
link to themselves, let
alone form a ring.
And so now, if we go through
this, we will put, from each
of these junctions there's the
carbon, so we have to have
four struts.
We need hydrogen, so let's put
hydrogens 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, So
there's the 6 hydrogens.
And now, each carbon
needs 4 struts.
So 1, 2, 3, and I'll
put a double bond.
That will make 4.
1, 2, 3, 4, 1, 2, 3, 4, 1, 2,
3, 4, and now this one here.
So you have an alternating
structure of double bond,
single bond, double bond, single
bond on the carbons.
OK?
So that's the way things stood
until the twentieth century,
when on the basis of new data,
it was discovered that all
carbon-carbon bonds--
and I don't want to make this
a single bond, I'll just say
all carbon-carbon bonds in
benzine, C6H6, were measured
to be the same length.
Well, that's a problem,
isn't it?
That's a problem, because we
would expect that, you know,
we know that carbon-carbon
single bond is about 1.47
angstroms, and the carbon-carbon
double bond has
to be shorter, because it's
double-bond, it's tighter, so
it pulls things in.
So that's 1.33 angstroms. And
the measurement here was found
to be 1.39 angstroms. And 1.39
angstroms is midway between
1.47 and 1.33.
So people were frustrated with
this new information.
And it was Linus Pauling who
made sense of this for us.
Pauling, who in 1931 came
along and said,
what we have a mix?
What if we have a mix
of two structures?
And he said, suppose you had
something that looked like so.
1, 1, 1.
So here's the set of double
bonds off of the ring.
And what if there is a resonance
with an opposite
hybrid, where this double bond,
instead of being here,
goes over to here?
So now we have this?
And he said, if the system
resonated between the
structure on the left and the
structure on the right, the
time average value of the
carbon-carbon bond length
would be around 1.39 angstroms.
So this is a
resonant hybrid structure, to
account for the mix of single
and double bonds, which gives
rise to the current
representation of benzine
as simply this.
So we're not saying this
is single or double.
It's a resonant between
one and two.
OK.
The other thing is, if all of
these bonds are the same
length, and that means that
between the 12:00 position
here and the 2:00 position,
there is pi bonding, and then
along this double bond, there's
pi bonding, and then
along this double bond,
there's pi bonding.
But if all of the bonds are the
same length, I can't say
that the pi bonds are confined
to where the double bonds are
indicated, because resonance
indicates that it could be
between adjacents.
So that means that
the electrons, in
fact, can go all around.
So resonance, then, means that
the pi electrons are
delocalized.
And now here's some
better drawings.
It's hard to draw that.
So here they are.
OK.
So this is a nicer drawing
of benzine.
So you can see, when all of
these bonds are resonant, it
doesn't matter whether I choose
this front one as the
double bond, or the
one next to it.
They're all the same length,
and so the electrons can go
all around.
And you can imagine, if I did
this with graphite, and I kept
going, well, if the electron can
go here, then it means it
can go here, which means it can
go here, which means it
can go everywhere.
Which is why graphite is an
electronic conductor, because
of delocalized pi bonds.
OK.
This is 1-3-butadiene.
Double bond, single
bond, double bond.
Again, all the same length, and
you can hybridize, and--
This is how you start making
electronically conducted polymers.
You just go double bond,
single bond.
Double bond, single bond.
Smear.
That's it.
OK.
Let's jump over that.
Let's talk about Kekule So he
studied architecture, switched
to chemistry.
And then he got a job in London,
and he used to fall
asleep on the bus to
his apartment.
And one day he was sleeping
on the bus.
He woke up, and he'd been
dreaming about carbon forming
chains in 1855.
And he proposed carbon chains.
And then he got a job as a
professor in Belgium, at the
University of Ghent.
And one night he fell asleep
at the fireplace, and he
dreamt of a benzine molecule
as a snake biting its tail
while spinning.
And that's where he got the
idea of the ring molecule.
All he knew was that this thing
had a formula, C6H6.
And for this, he's dubbed
the founder
of structural chemistry.
So what's this formula
for success?
Well, he moved into chemistry
from another field.
But to dream, you've got
to get some sleep.
And I'm probably talking to one
of the most sleep-deprived
populations on this campus.
So I urge you to get some sleep,
and then maybe you'll
be able to dream.
Hey, don't make noise.
We've got two minutes left.
nobody's going anywhere.
All right.
So the next thing is, I want
to talk a little bit about
octane ratings and automobiles,
and how we go
from straight chains to chains
of different lengths.
If you're looking at combustion,
the idea is, you
admit gasoline, which vaporizes,
and then the piston
comes up, and under
high compression,
the spark plug fires.
When the spark plug fires, this
causes an explosion which
then pushes the piston down,
and then you've got the
camshaft that takes the vertical
motion and converts
it to rotary motion.
Now, if you're running an
automobile after a certain
period of time, the combustion
chamber becomes so hot that
just admitting the fuel, having
it vaporized, before
the piston has risen fully to
get maximum compression, this
thing could just explode.
And when it explodes, it'll send
the piston down, and it's
out of sequence with
the other pistons.
And that's when you
get the knocking.
Sometimes you're driving
up hill, you hear this
[GRINDING SOUND].
That's the knocking going on.
You need to get a tune-up,
or switch to
higher octane gasoline.
So what's going on in here?
What you're doing, is you're
changing the chemical
composition, the constitutional
isomerization.
And you do that in the process
by which you synthesize the
gasoline in the first place.
So the figure of merit is called
octane number, which
was first instituted here
in the United States.
And they started with
2-2-4-trimethyl-pentane.
It's an octane, but it's
an octane that's 2-2-4.
Three methyl branches.
So that means there's
only five left.
So it's a pentane with three
methyl branches.
And that's called 100.
And then is 0 is heptane.
If you put heptane into the
combustion chamber, you'll
knock yourself silly.
And the engine will just shake
and shake and shake.
So gasolines have to be
somewhere on that interval.
So there's the-- you know,
if you tested and you had
something that was
trimetylpentane, 90%, versus
10% heptane, you'd call
it a 90% octane.
And you can have octane
numbers higher
than 100, by the way.
It just depends on what
the repression is.
And oddly enough, when you when
you increase the octane,
you make the fuel more
difficult to burn.
Because you want it to
burn only on demand.
Fuel that just burns whenever
it wants leads to random
events in the engine, and that's
not good, if you want
to get good thrust. So oddly
enough, high octane gasoline
requires more ignition
than low octane.
And the additives
are tetraethyl
lead or ethyl alcohol.
And from that, you know now, we
get E10, which is gasohol,
10% alcohol.
E85 is 85% ethyl alcohol.
And all of this you
get by synthesis.
You know, playing with the
catalysts, temperatures, and
so on, to get the right
mix to get good fuel,
and get good emissions.
And you can decide amongst
yourselves whether going to
E85 high levels of ethanol,
ethanol derived from corn, is
that smart, is that
food for fuel?
You know, what's the sensible
use of agriculture, algae,
switchgrass?
All of that stuff.
I mean, it's all loaded
into here.
All loaded into here.
So yeah.
With that, I think
we'll adjourn.
I'll see you on Wednesday.